um I was gonna say for you like you are
also like a huge actress
you are ins I mean you what was the uh
Glass Onion well I was like the horror
movie like was it Annabelle oh yes
Antebellum yeah
um for you when you're in like acting
mode right because I know it's it's a
lot to to like act and like you have to
give your mental space to like being
someone else does it take away a lot
from the music like do you have to be in
like okay I'm turning down roles because
I'm working on music or can you do both
simultaneously
I think with music I have to be in the
studio and hands on with it I can't just
you know I need to be writing
collaborating living it you know
um touching it feeling it I Engineer a
lot of my sessions so even you're
running your own Pro Tools yeah well I
work out of logic oh oh yeah shout out
to live workout logic yeah and I can
work out of Pro Tools but I prefer to do
logic um but yeah so just I need to be
super Hands-On with with music so I do
have to say no sometimes to you know
roles that may come in may come in and
sometimes that's difficult but music has
been so good to me a lot of the re you
know I think that I got a lot of my
movie roles because of my music career
because people were able to see me and
go into different characters with Glass
Onion the movie I just got finished
doing
um Ryan Johnson said that he was like I
saw that you could be you could embody
these different characters and this is
what we need in this movie you know it's
because of your film for dirty computer
and seeing you in your different music
videos and I was like oh she can do this
so um I'm gonna always make time for
music yeah what was it like working on
set with uh the Craig guy the
007 Daniel Craig I love Daniel I love I
love he's so humble who was James Bond
ever he he killed as James Bond and he's
so much more though too like I did even
just talking to him that role that he
plays in those two movies yeah that man
amazing no his range is just incred
incredible seeing them go from that
Southern drawl to you know I'm Daniel
Craig like the British accent
um such a sweetheart the whole cast
Edward Norton I mean Fight Club was like
it's like my top five me too um Kate
Hudson all of them legendary yeah that
was a wild uh cast if you just like it's
one of these movies how much was the
budget for this movie right exactly
exactly no we we had a wonderful time we
shot that in Greece and in fact it
actually made me
get inspired to do this album I I shot
that film and in the same year I wrote
this album really was it because Greece
is like a Vibe low-key it was vacation
Vibe yeah it's like oh man like what
kind of what do I want to hear when I'm
here you know when I'm on an island I
mean I didn't pay to go there I mean
obviously the studio got me there and I
was just so inspired and I started
thinking about how I wanted to feel even
when I couldn't go on vacation I need an
album that sounds like you're on
vacation and I just knew my producer was
sending me music while I was on set I
was picking the the the drums and
different things and by the time I shot
glass onion I came back I already had a
musical bed so you were in the trailer
like yeah
I definitely wrote and plotted
um well I'm also plotted a lot while I
was on set yeah has what has been the uh
most uncomfortable role you've played as
a uh as someone who acts because I do
feel like
there's a there's a lot that comes with
that gig you know you got to kind of die
I think Antebellum was tough yeah I
don't know if I'll ever do a role like
that again it was really tough to go and
be on a plantation and
you know play an enslaved person in
modern day times it was a lot on see
that seems deep it's heavy yeah it was
very heavy and it took a lot for me to
get that off of me too because
immediately after I wrapped my friends
were like let's go to Mexico and so I
was like well I need a vacation but I
couldn't shake that role and I would
just remember showing up
just like being super uneasy I'm like
girl what the [__] is wrong with you and
I'm like listen I lived basically lived
on the plantation for two months crazy
you know I did it for my reasons to
chant to honor you know my ancestors and
to bring awareness
um you know to to a lot of injustices
but yeah I don't think I think that was
probably my hardest so when they say
like when you act you can like get into
the role I just saw um uh the guy who
plays Franklin State on snowfall say he
like channeled the devil to be Franklin
sane in snowfall and he's like it like
it messed with him like after the show
was over a little bit yeah people don't
realize you're you're living and
breathing and I always you know stay out
into the universe like reduce Janelle
Monae I want you to see the spirit of
this character and and uh yeah a lot a
lot a lot of times it's hard to shake
those rows off